e
okay folks while while we're
waiting for people to come from the
other
room here's what's going to
happen
hi Kasha and Elanor
kha and elen or the T I'm going to take
the quizzes up to my office
and folks quiz is done talking about it
is not going to make a change right
they're going to take the quizzes
up no it's on people are just talking
too so loud
I won't help okay
so the quizzes will they'll take the
quizzes up to my room and they will sort
them
alphabetically by last name and leave it
on my desk I've already had three two
quizzes today I'm first in first out so
I'm going to do my Corporate Finance
quiz F first then I'll do
the would you ask you to just
hey
you
so I will get to the your quiz last in
the pile but it'll be sooner than you
think so I'll grade your
quizzes and when they're
graded could we please stop the
conversations on the side I know you
want to talk about the quiz but there's
a time and a place for it this isn't the
time and the
place so I will grade the quizzes and
when they're graded you will get an
email from me saying your quizzes are
done come and get
them they will be in alphabetical order
remember I asked you to write your name
on the back if you did not I will write
your name for you so hopefully 200 of
you didn't miss so it's a lot they'll be
faed down down in alphabetical order
pick up your quiz and when that email
comes I'll also send you the Excel
spreadsheet containing the
solution with a grading template so
basically you can check to see whether
the there's something that I've missed
and it's entirely possible because I
have 600 quizzes to grade tonight
tomorrow so there will there will be
things I miss especially as I get more
tired so if you let me know what I've
missed the only thing is it's a one-way
fix which is you will let me know the
things that you deserve credit for that
I've missed I don't think you're going
to let me know the mistakes that you
might have made that I missed but that's
okay I I accept that as part of the
consequence but let me know if there's
something that I've missed and I can
adjust the grade quickly so so wait for
that email it'll come at some point in
time and the quizzes will be I'll let
you know where to pick them up exactly
the physical
location so today I want continue and
complete our discussion of the terminal
value okay so Jake remind me
again why we put a cap on the growth
rate in the terminal value at the
risk-free rate so let's say I mean
because you you're going to get out
there many of you go know some of you
might do valuation you're going an
invest in banking group it's going to be
a Wharton grad there there's going to be
a Harvard grad there there's going to be
a Michigan grad there and you're in the
group and they're going to come up with
this the I think everybody accepts the
rule that the growth rate can't exceed
the growth rate of the economy that's a
simple one to accept right it's a
mathematical if you have somebody in the
group who doesn't even get that rule
they really don't belong in the group
but you have no power over that you're
stuck with an idiot in your group and
you got to kind of keep it but the
second rule of the risk-free rate being
the cap for the for the axy for that
noral growth rate in the economy is a
Messier one right I started on it and
some of you might might not have been
convinced so Jake get me started why is
the risk free rate a good proxy for the
nominal growth rate in the
economy see I didn't even convince Jake
he's trying to think there's no good
reason go ahead
perfect so the first is an economic
argument which is in the long term real
interest rates and real growth rates are
going to
converge because if they don't you'll
have an economy in which is imbalanced
and because they're going to converge
the risk-free rate becomes aoxy for the
noral growth rate the second is an
empirical argument which is if you look
across time and you look at the level of
the T bond rate and you look at the
level of noral growth growth rate the
two clearly moved together right look at
the 60s the 70s the 80s and especially
the last decade where interest rates
were low but so was inflation and real
growth turns out that over time and this
is a purely empirical argument the
risk-free rate does a pretty good job of
being a predictor of ninal growth in the
economy which also explains why European
risk free rates and Japanese risk free
rates have been so low right especially
Japan RIS free rates have been low for
30 years what is it about Japan that
makes risk free rates
low go back inflation and real growth
inflation has been low but what is it
about Japan that keeps real growth so
depressed it's demographics right you
have an aging population something to
think about as you go forward because
there are other countries that are South
Korea for instance now is a shrinking
population an aging population it's
tough to have real growth
when half the people in the country are
over the age of
65 the bigger scare of course is China
right that Tipping Point if it happens
is going to create some real growth
effects so the second argument is hey
even if you don't buy into that real
interest rate being equal to the real
growth rate it does a pretty good job of
forecasting a much better job than
what's your alternative if you don't use
the risk free rate is a proxy for the
nominal growth in the economy how else
are you going to get get
it you're going to have to ask some
macroeconomist what they think real
growth in the econom OR noral growth
will be not now but 10 years from now
fat lot of good that's going to do you
because there's almost no chance they're
going to give you an answer you can use
let's say that doesn't work either I'll
give you my third argument even if you
don't buy
into either of these arguments there's a
consistency argument let me explain
there are two places this number enters
into your valuation this number being
the risk free rate first it enters into
your discount rate so you risk free
rates are low what do you do to your
discount rates you also lower
them if you don't set your growth rate
at a number that is close to risk free
rate and risk free rates decrease as
they did in the last decade let's say
you continue to use the growth rates you
used to use in the n in the 2005 2007 or
even worse in the 1980s so using three
4% growth rate then you continue to use
that and your risk free rate has now
dropped to
1% play it out what's going to happen
your discount rates are going to be low
your growth rates are going to be 3 4 5%
because that's what you used to use your
values are going to explode because
you've mismatched your discount rate to
your growth rate so even if the first
two arguments don't work there's a
reason why you want to tie the two
because it prevents your valuations from
impling let me give you an example
you've heard of hinin
right most of you probably how many of
you are over the age of
21 I will assume the rest of you have
never had a beer in your life right but
when you get to the age of beer drinking
hinin is one of the best known brands in
the world so about September of
2019 I valued hin it's a Dutch brewery
and I valued the company in euros why
because I wanted to the numbers were all
in Euros I could have done a different
currency but see the risk free rate in
Euros at the time minus.
5% put in the negative risk free rate
you come up with the cost of capital
that's a tiny number 5% this is good
news right and normally when risk free
rates become low the analyst say well my
valuations are going to explode let's
see that happens in the hinen valuation
so I left the risk created a negative
number came up with a really low cost to
Capital then I turn to my cash flows I
have to live in the same world that my
negative risk free rate is coming from
right and what's that world a world of
low inflation and low real growth so
when I projected the growth for Heineken
I projected a growth rate of 3.22% a
year and I was being upbeat because it's
a mature company in a slowing economy
and I'm doing my valuation in an
deflationary currency so I gave them a
low growth rate three three people from
this from the hinek and finance group
are in the audience and didn't like the
growth rate but they kind of Let It Go
and then I get to my terminal
value and what's the growth rate I'm
assuming in perpetuity
Tyler my terminal
value no take a look again what's in
front of them it's first it's 05% and
there's a minus in front of it I'm
following my own rule risk free rate is
negative and these three people popped
out of they say said that's so unfair
you're giving us a negative growth rate
in perpetuity and I said you didn't
complain when I gave you a really low
cost of capital Did
you what one hand gives you the other
hand takes
away even with a negative risk free rate
the value that I got was well below the
stock price what I'm trying to say is
dispense with this notion that when risk
free rates Get Low your valuations are
all going to get higher if you stay
consistent and that's part of the reason
I want you to tie the growth rate the
risk rate rate your valuations will
never blow
up hinin is just not a good company I
don't like it just because risk free
rate is negative doesn't mean I should
find it undervalued this allows me to do
it conversely if you're valuing a
Turkish company remember what the risk
free rate look like 15% 18% you put that
in you come up with a really high
discount rate if I use whatever growth
rate I want 3 to 5% growth I'll save you
the trouble no Turkish compan is ever
going to look cheap to you but that's
because you're mismatching what's
happening in your cash flows in your
discounts so cap the growth rate at the
risk free rate and move on because it
going to it's going to save you a whole
host of troubles along the way second
yeah go
ahead after the remember the changes are
after the fact right so after the fact
you look back and say interest rates
changed a lot right so is this expected
interest rate change or act cuz at any
point in time the interest rate is what
it is right if I bought a bond that day
it's not at a shifting rate it's going
to be at the 10year bond rate that day
it's an opportunity cost if you're
saying the rate could be different
tomorrow yes so will everything else
right so let's say rates go up tomorrow
it could be because of higher inflation
in which case my growth rates could
could be because the economy is doing
much better than expected it's not just
the rate that is moving on a day-to-day
basis it's everything in your
valuation so tomorrow if you value the
company you can't just change the risk
free rate if it's changed dramatically
you got to say what else changes again
your whatever you do to your discount
rate play it out on all of your cash
flow
assumptions second stop remember you do
this only when you get to stable growth
right so you saying when will that be
will it be in 3 years 5 years 10 years
let's make a couple of statements that I
think are pretty Common Sense ones the
greater the size of the potential Market
relative to the size of your company the
more leeway you get Let It Grow for a
longer period you have a small grocery
store company let's say you're valuing
sprouts sprouts is a tiny grocery store
company in terms of market share if you
give it 30% growth because you have a
story for Sprouts growing I'm going to
let you do it if you feel that that's
your story because the market is huge
and even with the 30% growth rate for
the next 10 years routs will go from 3%
to 2 or 3% market
share conversely if you're looking at
Volkswagen in a mature automobile Market
the number of cars being sold has become
pretty stagnant more of them might be
electric but you're not selling 20% more
cars every year you have a large market
share of a market that's already
stagnant and you put in a 20% growth
rate for the next 5 or 10 years I have
some questions where's that growth
coming from who you getting it from
maybe you have a great story of
Volkswagen taking over the the entire
Global automobile
Market second and this goes with the
first one small companies you have more
leeway to put in high growth rate than
bigger companies scaling up is hard to
do and it catches up with
you now if you follow that up though
remember it's not growth that creates
value it's earning more than your cost
of capital right step back again why do
you earn more more than your cost of
capital because you have some
comparative advantage that you believe
you have so let me make a statement
about those competitive advantages
companies with strong and sustainable
competitive advantages can grow for
longer while creating value than
companies without those
advantages take a comp like
amjet biotech company what's its
competitive
advantage or do farmer company it's a
pattern you get legal protection against
competition sustainable yeah for a long
time as long as they keep the drug
pipeline open so you're valuing I am
might say I'm going to give them 15
years of
growth Coca-cola brand name long so this
is where that story part of your
analysis comes in companies you know
strong sustainable competitive
advantages can grow for much longer and
if you have a high growth company with
strong and sustainable competitive
advantages you now have this potential
of letting the growth continue margins
improve and create value as you
grow Airbnb went public only what 4
years ago November of
2020 strong compar what's that
comparative
advantage you want to
yeah well in terms of know first they
have a platform right first if you want
to rent an apartment or a or a house
anywhere in the US now you have only two
choices used to be that you could do
owner to owner rentals those days are
now done you either go go through
Expedia or you go through Airbnb so have
the platform so that's one competitive
Advantage everybody has to go through
and if you want to list your apartment
to rent guess what they have just as
much of an advantage because you can try
a private listing and try to get
somebody to come in but people are not
checking newspapers there used to be
time you looked at the classified ads
when was the last time any of you looked
at a classified ad would you even know
where to find
it so first is platform second is the
advantage that gives as they scale up
they get those competitive advantage of
collecting 14% that's what Airbnb takes
of every dollar that you spend on Airbnb
for maintaining the platform is it
sustainable depends on what it's a
technological platform it's sustainable
unless the technology somehow shifts and
chat GPT connects you with the renter
somewhere who knows that can happen AI
might do it but it is a sustainable
advantage in contrast to remember few
years ago when Groupon went
public and people had High Hopes about
growth and I know and I looked at what
it's what what is Groupon's competitive
Advantage they got your email faster
than everybody else's right how long
will that last it lasted like 15 minutes
because after Groupon got listed you got
a bunch of other companies doing exactly
that which is allowing retailers to list
and sell Surplus stuff at low prices
group on comparative advantages faded in
months rather than in
years so when you look at a company and
you tell how long do you wa third stop
remember again that the big number in
your terminal value is what you assume
about Returns on Capital in perpetuity
okay this is where the sustainable
Advantage argument comes
in so just to show you how much that
that end assumption matters here's what
I've done I've taken a company which
basically is in steady state so in
stable growth and effectively computed
the terminal value with a combination of
two assumptions growth rate forever and
a return Capital perpetuity let's say
this company's cost of capital is
10% returning capital is 10% I can
change the growth rate from 0% to 3% my
terminal value stays exactly the same
you take the same company give it a 8%
return on Capital you change the growth
rate the terminal value actually
decreases as the growth rate goes up if
you give it a 12% return on Capital
increases now my book came out in the
late 1980s my first valuation book it
came out from John Wy was my publisher
was published at exactly the same time
that McKenzie published its valuation
book and we we at that time at least
those were the only two books on
valuation the Mackenzie book on
valuation was written by know by two
people who worked at McKenzie and so
both of books were used
widely and the big difference in the
McKenzie book is they had a terminal
value equation and here's what they had
as terminal value no plat which is after
tax operating income in the
numerator divid by cost of capital there
was no growth
rate so the longest time I'd get emails
from people reading the book saying I'm
reading the McKenzie book I'm in the
terminal value section I have this
terminal value equation why is there no
growth in the terminal value to which my
my response usually was why are you
writing to me write to mcken
but they thought because we had the same
publisher we kind of hung out together I
don't know where and talk to each other
all the time about
valuation but you know why McKenzie's
valuation book there is no G in the
denominator what happens to the growth
rate if the return capital is equal to
the cost of capital it doesn't matter
right might as well use a 0% growth rate
and McKenzie actually explicitly assumed
that if you were a mature company in
stable growth that you could not earn
more than your cost of capital now you
can see right right in the long-term
compared advantages faade the only
problem is putting it in your 10
basically means every company your
Coca-Cola and your Groupon will look
exactly the same because they're all
required to I think it's too rigid but
if you make that assumption you don't
need growth in your equation it's
actually a good message to deliver when
analyst get caught up and should my
growth rate be 3 or 4% my question is
what kind of business are you in are you
in a business can know well above your
cost of capit in which case we should
spend time talking about it but if
you're in a fairly neutral business
where you roughly earn your cost of
capital who cares what the growth rate
is might as well use a zero growth rate
you get exactly the same terminal value
so let's review the growth rate cannot
exceed so when you when when you think
about projecting growth it cannot exceed
the growth rate of the economy we use
the risk free rate the big assumption is
your return on Capital assumption
and in fact McKenzie in their own
research undercut what they wrote In the
book so McKenzie actually publishes a
journal called McKenzie quarterly those
of you it's free so basically if you go
and register on their side I'd strongly
recommend you do they actually this
publication they use their own internal
data that they have from clients the
data they've collected over Decades of
having know companies as their clients
and the research basically looks at what
they found so one there one of the
graphs they have in the in that research
shows you what happens to revenue growth
at companies over time so as they get
bigger as you can see the revenue growth
drops off it converges on the growth
rate of the economy so that's a good
news right you can put them in terminal
value they also track what happens to
returns and capital over time and what
they find is companies that survive a
long time many of them are able to
maintain returns of capital above their
cost of capital for
decades and what do theyum assuming
they're assuming that every company in
your 10 earns its cost of capital growth
rate doesn't
matter I don't know how many of you have
actually done valuations in your
internships but there are valuations
that people do in terminal value where
they make a combination of assumptions
that essentially get them into trouble
let's see what those assumptions are
first they will assume that their
companies in stable growth it's a mature
company so far so good they'll give it a
growth rate of 2% a year less than the
risk fre rate still good right and then
they will say mature
companies capex offsets depreciation
what does that
mean net capex is zero working capital
needs are
negligible change in working capital is
zero the risk of sounding incredibly
stupid what's 0 plus 0 zero so the
reinvestment is
zero and then they will do that in the
terminal value these value s that
terminal value is just on the verge of
implosion here's why if your
reinvestment rate is zero in steady
state what's the only growth rate you
can use you should be using a zero
growth rate but they use a 2% growth
rate because this is what they've always
done so if you run into discounted cash
flow valuation that terminal value that
combination those comb that combination
cannot live because it's internally
inconsistent I usually don't talk about
the quiz because it does create angst
and then you're beating yourself up but
there was a problem I asked you for free
cash flow to the firm
right it had two components to it that
were a little tricky one is it been a
firm that had been around only one year
and had lost money in the last year was
expected to make money next year why is
that
relevant because it does affect your
taxes why did I have to tell you it's
been around only one year because it
been around more years and I have to
give you more information about the no
because it's been around only one year
that loss become the other was I gave
you no information about capex and
depreciation and working capital right
so how did he get free cash flow to the
firm without that
information what do you
sopia ah okay invested C Capital right
what so let's say you do capex where
does it go go think in no we didn't we
don't think like accountant but capex
goes into the balance sheet as an asset
right it pushes up your book Equity your
book Debt depending on how you funded it
it goes into invested Capital what
happens when you have depreciation it
comes out of invested Capital what
happens if your working capital
increases it goes into invested capital
I know know I talked about it indirectly
when I did the but every reinvestment is
your Delta in invested
Capital right so you take the change in
invested
Capital there's no more need for
assumptions that is your net cap X Plus
change in working capital plus
Acquisitions plus R&D because that is
the
shift and that's basically what we're
looking for here you put in growth I
need to see a reinvestment otherwise
what happens your invested Capital stays
Frozen your operating income Rises to %
a year every year what's going to happen
to your return on Capital over time if
you have the same invested Capital your
Opera income keeps Rising your return
invested capital is going to go to
infinity and beyond because it just
doesn't make
sense and finally be internally
consistent when you put your company to
stable growth you are bringing the
growth rate down that's a bad news at
least give it the
characteristics of a mature company what
is those what what will those include
first if you have a company right now
with the beta of 2.5 it's a risky
company okay that makes sense you're a
risky high growth company but in your
spreadsheet what are you doing you're
making it into a mature company which is
moneymaking and positive cash flows it's
beta should start to move towards one
why because that's the average bait
across all companies your cost of
capital is 14% to begin with okay I can
live with that if you're a risky company
but if you still leave it at 14% and
make this company a mature company you
are going to undervalue the company
because you're not being internally con
consist I'm listening to your story and
trying to make sure that the numbers
you're using reflect your story so if
you tell me your company goes from high
growth to low growth low margins to high
margins I'll go along but then I want to
see a cost of capital that shifts down
maybe even your return on Capital start
to move towards your cost of
capital so when you look at your
terminal value your terminal value
should reflect the story you're telling
about the company not today but 10 years
after
so when you look at my Tesla valuation
my Tesla numbers in year 10 are not the
Tesla of today they're are very
different Tesla one of my biggest you
know issues with valuation is people
will change the growth rate but
everything else about the company
remains like it is today that's a
mismatch your story is at war with
itself and your valuation can't send
up so any questions on the terminal
values so let's summarize the rules in
ter value uhuh tell me what the basic
rules are so when you're coming to your
10 what are some of the things you're
checking what's your first
stop your terminal value calculation
what are some of the things you're
checking
on no no so all of those go to the
equation but what do you CH so let's say
you're looking at my discounted cash
flow valuation you're checking the
terminal value equation take input by
input and tell me what checks are
running let's start with the growth rate
what's the first check you
run just compare to your risk free rate
and see if I'm using a growth rate less
than the risk free rate first stop done
second stop you look at the cost of
capital what are you checking
there what is it changed over time so if
you start with the 15% did you bring it
down so the cost of capital changing
over time you get to the cash flow
you're looking for reinvestment right
you want to make sure the reinvestment
rate I'm using reflects the 2% growth
rate I have in year 10 not not the 20%
growth rate I have today go input by
input to make sure your terminal
value because if you don't your terminal
value can take off with your valuation
and all the hard work you put to get
your free cash for the next 10 years has
gone to waste so I'm going to send you
the the the practice webcast for this
month is actually a terminal value
Checker it's a little Excel spreadsheet
we can take the terminal value numbers
put it in and it says this doesn't make
sense this doesn't connect I won fix it
for you but I said this doesn't make
sense do you want to
change so last piece of just the
intrinsic value pu we've talked about a
lot of ways you can do discounted cash
flow valuation right you can discount
different kinds of cash flows dividends
free cash flow Equity free cash flow of
firm you can choose different discount
rates cost of equity cost of capital you
can have high
growth valuations or you can have mature
growth
valuations you're saying how do I pick
which cash flow to discount
which discount rate to choose and what
growth pattern to adopt so think of like
this like essentially like a Lego box
you're trying to decide which Lego
pieces to bring together let's start
with the first one which cash flow
should I
discount you could go lazy and use the
dividend discount model
right because every company there is a
dividend number when would you use the
dividend discount model when you get
really desperate and you cannot estimate
free cash flows at all what kind
companies would that be how many of you
doing financial service
companies estimating free cash flow at
least at this stage is going to be messy
because capex depreciation working
capital all for together we use the
dividend discount model not because we
want to but because we have no
choice so when you think about dividend
discount models they kind of hang in
with those companies because you can't
estimate cash flows in general if you
get to that first Branch Equity
valuation or firm valuation in general
Equity valuation models are more
restrictive than firm valuation models
because they require you to make
assumptions in fact even to get free
cash Ro Equity remember all those line
items at to forecast capex depreciation
working capital debt issue debt repaid
you're going to be pulling your hair out
free cash Lo Equity is easier if you
assume a constant debt ratio remember
the Disney case I used to so if you have
a stable leverage firm a firm where the
debt ratio is set right now and will
never change do Equity valuation
everywhere else value the entire
business in most of your valuations I
expect to see firm valuations rather
than Equity valuations because it's very
unusual to find a firm which has a debt
ratio okay I'm going I can stick with
that debt
ratio now is to cash flows at dividends
with with dividends you're doing it
because you're desperate you can't no
and you can value a bank which doesn't
pay dividends with a dividend discount
model sound like a weird thing to say
how would I value a bank with no
dividends with the dividend discount
model and but you in fact you make a
growth assumption remember return and
Equity assumption in fact you would
estimate a payout ratio which right now
is zero but as the growth in this Bank
levels off or becomes lower you're going
to be this is the advantage of
revisiting assumptions is you can use a
dividend discount model for non-dividend
paying Bank
by forecasting out what the payout ratio
will be in year one year two year three
and as your growth comes down your
payout ratio is going to kick up and you
can value the bank
yes no no wait tell me so let's play it
out it's in a bank let's go through the
free cash Equity calculation what is the
number starts with free cash net income
can I get that for a bank yeah yeah
let's go next line item what's the next
line
item yeah let's pause what iation you're
going to find in a bank income
statement almost nothing right almost
nothing real estate doesn't depreciate
it's land and most you know the building
depreciates very little so what what
about
capex what about working
capital some level everything is working
capital
Right But it includes things like
repurchase on both side you're getting
really mixed up as to what it it you
very quickly start to give up so you can
try but at least the way we compute free
cash for other firms doesn't work for
banks little later in this class I'm
going to talk about perhaps a creative
way of coming up with free cash Ro
equity for a bank but the traditional
definition of free cash Road Equity is
just run into a brick
wall so use dividends in companies where
you really can't you given up you really
don't know what the Free Cash Road
Equity is there's not enough information
that's the only thing you given use a
free cash Equity model but you do it
only when the Leverage is stable because
if it's not it's a real mess to computer
it's not that it's not wrong it's just
really the pragmatic choice too much
work now once you pick the cash flow
though the discount rate picks itself if
you decide to Discount dividends your
discount rate has to be at this point it
should be almost second nature which
which which discount rate you use if you
discount
dividends come on you just finished the
quiz it was problem one in every quiz
right should be the cost of equity
in fact while we're here we might as
well ask that question you saw in the
quiz what if your cash flows are risk-
free what did you use as a cost of
capital for your risk-free
piece which
is why do you use the risk
credit right so he's saying what you
need the cost cap for the 60% that they
sell to businesses you know what you're
saying this is such a madeup example you
value p
valer benter gets revenues from the
defense department it also gets revenues
from commercial establishments very
similar to this example right on a much
bigger
scale the risk you the discount rate
used on a cash flow should reflect the
risk in the cash flows risk free the
risk free
rate what currency should use for the
discount
rate Sophia
used for the cash flows right see
already with the discount rate the
choices got made when you did the cash
flows because once you chose to use to
estimate the cash flows in Euros
discount rate has to be in Euros it's in
to equity it's got to be the cost of
equity you say what about nominal versus
real again I'm going to ask you how you
got the cash flows if those are nominal
cash flows which are often the case when
you do currencies the discount rate has
to be normal the real so discount rates
have to be matched stop to cash
flows third
stop say how do I get to terminal value
because remember you got to get there if
you have a company that is already a low
Growth Company it's 2% growth can you do
the terminal value calculation right off
the top and be
done do you have to forecast 10 years of
cash
flows you could but it'll make no
difference if you don't believe me take
the number
projecti out cash flows at a 10% growth
2% growth rate for the next 10 years and
after the 10th year putting a 2% growth
rate forever calculate the present value
and then do one stable growth equation
today with the 2% growth rate you will
get the same
value if any of you have picked a mature
company with a stable growth rate you
know with a growth rate of two 2 and a
half% where things have settled in
that's critical as well your cost of
capital is settled in you're not going
to change your debt ratio your valuation
will require only three numbers your
cash flow next year already some of you
saying maybe I should pick go choose a
different company if you have a big you
know Stable Company you're already in
stable
growth you might have a company where
there is some growth left over youing
Levi stra pretty mature business right
but there's still some residue of growth
they they don't they're not big in Asia
yet maybe they can convince Asians to
wear more jeans that could create
another F but it's not going to be 50%
growth it's going to be 5 6 7% growth
it's not going to last that long and if
you want to go from 5 to 2% no you can
do it at the end of your that's a
two-stage mod growth for a particular
period than you but that Cliff of
dropping off becomes much more
problematic if you have a 40% growth or
a 50% growth rate right you don't go
from 50 to two so this is just common
sense you create a transition period to
get from 50 to 2 the simple Ginsu
spreadsheet that I sent you will work
for any three firms basically it's
malleable enough but basically it's it's
it allows your growth rate to transition
over
time so I wasn't kidding when I said
this is like Lego blocks every
discounted cash flow model that you will
ever run into there will have a
combination of cash flows discount rates
and a growth pattern and it can create a
100 different variants doesn't make them
100 different ways of valuing companies
they just reflect the reality of what
your company looks like and the one
thing you cannot do is force different
Lego boxes that are not supposed to
Legos that are not supposed to go
together to each other use a cost of
capital with a cash flow Equity use
Dollar Cash discount rates with Euro
cash flows so as long as you preserve
that principle of
consistency these things are all going
to work so I want you to start thinking
about your company valuation because I
know I now you just finished the quiz
but towards the end of this month you
get that one time I know most of you
haven't actually started valuing your
company
yet maybe some of you haven't even
picked your company yet and you just
lied to me about this pick a company
start working on that because things are
only going to start jamming up together
as you go through so take that
spreadsheet that I sent you and I
actually start a base case valuation
this evening it could be a first run and
you can always come back and review and
adjust and
adapt so I will see you on Wednesday and
we will continue our discussion of the
rest evaluation that we've got the
mechanics nailed down
much of what they
this
go ahead
Happ
my
e
e e